ah oui ou non je chéris des patrons
c'est pas un truc c'est cyrille maret
pont des séries c'est cyril le plus
intelligent le plus beau le mieux
habillé évidemment déléguant plus
glamour et plus jeunes et passent plus
il est beau vous trouvez voilà voilà
c'est bien on s'y met tiens j'ai rédigé
pour vos descriptions se faisait un
petit accent vérité d'accord allait leur
action vérité action à action prenait
des risques non vérité a trop tard
actions et des actions non c'est lui qui
a maintenant alors vous ces actions mais
attention alors envoyé à cyril le sms tu
fais le show en plateau mais en été tu
es un fragile c'est maintenant d'accord
ok merci et vous et vous voulez vérité
vérité quelle chroniqueurs et le peu
différent à l'antenne et hors antenne
d'accord elle répondait elle répondait
mur pour le texto approchez-vous
prochaine on attendait mais notre main à
temps en temps il n'y a pas d'autres
téléphones avant tu es gentil jean
lecomte aux accents vérité j'ai donc
lancé à des filles vous avez relevé
assez merdique mans je dois le dire
nicolas mais vous vous envoyer un texto
à cyril en plateau du seul effet je vous
montrerai après le show en réalité tu es
un fragile était fragile d'accord mais
je le fais moi je m'en fous tu fais le
jour on est en réalité tu es fragile 1
tarbes agir a ajouté que toi et on en
voit on en voit voilà voilà voilà c'est
parti mon avis ça va répondre assez vite
j'ai vu le garmin et un pétage que les
biens quatre ont encore de la bourse et
il nous a répondu très gentiment
alors on va rappeler qu'on l'a fait un
axe aux vérités l'actionnaire est envoyé
un petit texto de jeudi en plateau que
tu fais le show moralité thème choisi
lanta il m'a répondu
nick du toit et lui là dans la rue on
imite boulot ça tu as cru que j'étais
copain de tf1 je vais vous [ __ ] sa
définition simultanés avaient alors
répond lui que d'aller au bout font que
de la gueule de la guenon fond voilà